les plumes sont à l'oiseau ce que la
moyenne sur les tons hope for
indissociables tous les oiseaux porte
des plumes oiseaux terrestres compris
pourtant leurs ancêtres n'ont pas
toujours été pourvus aussi aujourd'hui
je vous propose de voir ce que sont les
plus et comment elles ont évolué mais
avant de me lancer dans une revue
historique de ces formidables phanères
un petit point définition s'impose et
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de
définition
les salaires c'est ce qu'on appelle dans
le jargon scientifique des productions
tégument terre autrement dit toutes les
structures externes que produit notre
peau les pois les écailles et bien sûr
les plumes en font partie mais aussi les
ongles la corde qui entoure les griffes
ou encore le belge des choses c'est ça
des structures majoritairement en
kératine plus c'est ça au bout se trouve
le cas l'anus le tuyau creux qui est la
partie attaché à l'oiseau qui se
poursuit ensuite parlera china partie
pleine de la tige autour de ce rachat
vient de se placer des deux victimes qui
sont les deux parties plates en quelques
centres de la plus sexy ils sont
constitués de bar les petites fibres
qu'on peut voir à l'oeil nu quand on
tire un peu sur l'élection
et c'est parle sont alain clôt le point
d'ancrage de barbus qui porte elle même
de minuscules parmi celles qui forment
comme de petits crochets attachants les
barbes entre elles pour assurer la
cohésion de l'ensemble
une prime plus à partir d'un bonjour le
germe plus mère dans lequel se développe
plusieurs tissus qui donne naissance à
la plume
petit à petit la plus grande île
protégée par une gaine corner qu'elle
finit par craquer lorsque la poussette
presque terminé une fois la puce terminé
la plume restera en place jusqu'à la
prochaine
[Musique]
or toutes les primes ne sont pas pareils
certaines sont très souples d'autres
beaucoup plus rigide tout dépend de leur
pétition sur le corps de l'oiseau et de
leur utilisation au chi excuse moi mais
attend les pattes et plus ou moins
couverts de plumes
[Musique]
c'est pas toi qu'il peignit et diminue
trop plein de vocabulaire en plus les
petits risques ne concerne que les pubs
les plus colorés le duvet ils poussent
partout
au niveau des équipes de plume c'est
assez diversifiée les plus connus sont
les plumes de vol ou peine
elles sont très solides pour résister
aux contraintes physiques du vol on
distingue les rémiges les primes de vol
des ailes qui sont généralement
asymétrique et les actrices ou plumes de
la queue qui sont souvent beaucoup plus
symétrique
selon plume s'appelle les reliques et
sandwich tin oo à la juge takashi rocher
depuis quand êtes-vous ses clients à
migrer cyr merlin ensuite viennent des
plumes plus petit et moins rigide
lectrices plume de couverture ce sont
les petites plumes colorées qui couvrent
l'oiseau sur le reste du corps
c'est plus me semble une sorte de mentor
souvent plus ou moins imperméable qui
recouvre le duvet les plumes très bus
qui garde la chaleur ou la fraîcheur wii
et qui elles le sont absolument parfaite
pour résister aux intempéries
souvent on retrouve aussi des plumes qui
sont à moitié des plumes de couverture
est à moitié fait de tuer ce sont les
soli plumes
j'y viens les filles occupent sont des
petites plumes très fine qui ont
l'aspect de poêle avec une sorte de plus
monde
elles sont implantées au voisinage des
lectrices et des plumes de vol et sont
souvent bien plus petit que les autres
non c'est pas grand chose pour le moment
on pensait qu'il s'agissait d'une
dégénérescence de certaines pubs ou
encore calé des oiseaux lors de sa
toilette
il semblerait aussi qu'elle faisait un
rôle dans le remplacement des plumes
groupés ou tomber
[Musique]
le
il existe un autre type de plume qui
ressemble à des poils ce sont les
vibrisses ces petites plumes filiforme
se trouve sur le contour du bec et des
yeux les livres y certes touché et sont
particulièrement développées chez les
espèces insectivores ou nocturnes et ça
fait aussi beaucoup de plumes sur chaque
oiseau
on en compte pas moins de 900 sur un
colibri et jusqu'à 25000 sur les grands
signes plutôt oui la masse totale des
plumes d'un oiseau pour représenter
jusqu'à 50 % de son poids
c'est loin d'être négligeable eh ben
pour le savoir un faire un tour du côté
des fossiles les oiseaux actuels donc le
boule de plumes favorites ont pour
origine le groupe très diversifié des
dinosaures qu'on qualifie trop souvent
de géant et cailloux et c'est au sein de
ce groupe qu'on peut observer
l'évolution des plumes et parce que les
dinosaures c'est plein de noms et de
groupes qu'on ne connaît pas forcément
part car je vais me baser sur cette file
au génie et on va la remonter petit à
petit jusqu'à arriver aux oiseaux
modernes
donc vous avez l'échelle des temps
géologiques ans au seuil du trias à la
limite crétacé tertiaire ont fait
d'assez cénozoïque est en dessous les
différents groupes de dinosaures et le
temps qu'ils ont passé sur terre jusqu'à
leur extinction
et oui la plupart des groupes de
dinosaures se sont éteints à la fin du
crétacé très ne se poursuive pas dans la
période suivante parce qu'ils ne sont
plus présents tout simplement
mais tu vois le groupe qui a donné les
oiseaux modernes lui pose sa limite
bref pour faire simple je vais prendre
une espèce par groupe et vous donner les
plumes ou les types de plume qui sont
présentes on va les mettre ici en
référence à la et ça ça va nous
permettre de voir les changements qui se
produisent au fil du temps à aller c'est
parti alors je crois pas qu'on puisse
exactement parler de plus à ce stade
nous on peut trouver des sortes de
structures fibreuse chez certains en
mitissien comme si ta cause aux russes
ou encore tianyu l'aude
oui pour l'instant ce sont juste des
filaments
nous ce qu'on nomme d'ailleurs des mono
filament par contre un autre en crise
qui a entraîné structure un peu
différente sécu linda drôme et us ce
petit animal portée à la fois des
écailles des mono filament et glissante
de petites plaques portant chacune
plusieurs filaments ce serait une sorte
de proto plus
autrement dit l'un des premiers stades
amenant à la formation des plumes tels
qu'on les connaît actuellement
alors non non pas du tout en fait lui
c'est un cousin un ancêtre
tiens regarde là ce sont les dinosaures
c'est par les apprentis skieurs et son
lescun contrairement à ce que leur nom
pourrait faire penser ce sont les soeurs
est ce qu'un il en avant les sens aux
oiseaux modernes
al'inverse les ornithischiens ne sont
que de vague cousin éloigné de solutions
liées plumes sont peut-être apparue à
plusieurs reprises dans des groupes
d'animaux différents c'est ce qu'on
appelle un cas d évolution convergente
[Musique]
ou bien alors tous les ancêtres des
dinosaures avaient en moindre mesure des
filaments qui ont fui relayant
protoplumes plus tard c'est possible
qu'on en n'ait pas retrouvé parce que ce
sont des structures assez fragile qui
fragilise vraiment mal chez les souris
ce cas on l'a aussi les animaux qui
possèdent des filaments comme chez les
années fiscales sur une muse par exemple
c'est finalement se développe un peu
dans les groupes suivants non des sortes
de filaments plus large et même des
filaments progrès ensemble en proto plus
c'est le cas chili tyrannis et peut-être
aussi fille ornitho minutes
chez sinosauropteryx ce sont des
protoplumes qui ressemble beaucoup au
fil aux plumes à prince au poil
regroupés au boudin rachis et c'est
aussi le cas chez pika aux russes
hassidim aux russes monte d'un cran dans
le développement des plumes avec des
filaments qui se branchent entre eux
pour former comme un rachis centrale
agrémentée deux par deux sur les côtés
il porte ainsi ce qu'on considère être
le début des vraies plumes enfin chez
encore nice on trouve une accumulation
de plusieurs types de plumes et
notamment de vraies plumes type plume de
couverture donc encore symétrique
on retrouve plus ou moins la même chose
chez john yang wallonne et microraptor
avec la petite différence que cette fois
ci il y a aussi des plumes véritablement
asymétrique
donc ils plus de vols à partir de là les
espèces comme archéoptéryx et jeholornis
ainsi que les groupes suivants ont des
plumes asymétrique rappelant les oiseaux
modernes
d'ailleurs on commence aussi à voir sur
jeholornis l'apparition de caractères
plus à vient comme la dégénérescence des
dents par exemple ce qui le rapproche
encore un peu plus de noble de plus
moderne ou pas j'ai déjà eu ma dose de
défier orthophonique pour aujourd'hui
alors il s'est déjà prononcée tous et
nous le payons doha après ouais bah
voilà un os il manque quelques bestioles
c'est vrai mais ça permet de voir dans
l'ensemble comment les plumes ont évolué
et c'est ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui on pourra toujours revenir
sur chaque spécimen séparément une autre
et puis surtout j'avais envie de vous
parler de génie ce qui s'est passé
depuis la génétique non sus aux non
c'est non
promis je fais simple en plus on n'a
même pas parlé de la méthode combat
juste parler des résultats grâce aux
fossiles il est possible de retracer
l'évolution générale des plumes même si
quelques détails nous échappe encore en
ajoutant la génétique on peut préciser
le trait par exemple nous savons que les
premières protoplumes sont en réalité
les sortes de filaments simple mais ce
fait nous ne savons pas si doux si
filaments pro vient-il grâce à des
études en génétique qu'il a été possible
de reconstituer ses premiers pas dans la
formation des plus tout part de la peau
la peau est constitué de plusieurs
couches l'épiderme surface le derme au
milieu et enfin l'hypoderme en dessous
c'est dans le dernier que tout va se
jouer pour la formation des plumes car
pour la plupart c'est la quête de sens
lors du développement le derme devient
plus épais par endroits grâce notamment
à l'ajout de kératine des cellules qui
la produisent comme la kératine qui sont
dans les pubs c'est ça la kératine se
retrouve concentré dans de petits
boutons les plats cote qui viennent
parsemer la peau c'est placotent sont
les futurs beaujon plus mer dont vous
sortir les plumes il est d'ailleurs à
noter que les écailles les reptiles et
les poils des manières se forme de la
même manière en commençant par une
plaque hot tout à fait similaire à celle
qui servira aux dieux une plume la seule
différence ce sont les gènes qui
s'exprime ensuite lorsque la plume puce
par conséquent il est assez facile de
conclure que les poils les plus et les
écailles ont tous une origine commune
alors désolé de te décevoir mais si
vieux que la plupart des descendants des
groupes de dinosaures et mammifères ont
des plats code on en est rapidement venu
à penser que leurs ancêtres communs donc
quelque part avant la différenciation
entre rétive et les petits maliens
avaient déjà des plats code ce qui aura
permis plus tard l'évolution des
différents types de faber poil écailles
et plus
pour conclure on considère que
l'évolution des plumes suis plus ou
moins l'ordre d'apparition de ces
structures dans le registre fossile dans
l'ordre d'apparition nous avons d'abord
le filament simple puis la jonction de
plusieurs filaments pour former
protoplumes du duvet ensuite le
développement des barbes et des barbus
pour enfin arriver au plus de couverture
munis de barres bull et de bab ciel puis
aux plumes de vol asymétrique
ce modèle explique assez bien la
diversité des plumes que l'on retrouve
chez les fossiles mais aussi sur les
espèces actuelles par ailleurs il nous
renseigne aussi sur l'utilisation de ces
premières plumes
sachant que les plumes de vol sont
apparus en dernier il est assez aisé de
comprendre que le vol n'était pas le but
premier des plumes
aujourd'hui il est admis que les plumes
des dinosaures service surtout à du
signalement que ce soit pour les parades
nuptiales ou d'autres types de
communication entre individus
on invoque aussi son utilité comme outil
de protection thermique les écailles ne
protège pas contre que le froid mais les
plumes
oui ce n'est que plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'années après leur apparition
que les dinosaures ont commencé à les
utiliser pour plané puis enfin pour le
vol battu le vrai celui qui les emmenait
d'un coup d'aile ouvert à les oiseaux
actuels
[Musique]
oh
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur les
plumes des oiseaux j'ai deux livres
proposés d'abord pour les plus férus de
nature et de grands espaces ceux qui
aiment les randonnées sauvage et savoir
à qui appartient la plume à bordeaux b
sur le chemin ce guide est vraiment
fantastique
ensuite pour ceux qui n'ont pas peur de
l'anglais des publications scientifiques
et des livres de chevet un peu costaud
celui là résume assez bien l'état actuel
des connaissances et m'a aidé à faire
cet épisode sur l'évolution des plumes
sur ceux à bientôt
à
[Musique]